okay well you clearly don't care so why
don't you just leave I would like to
stay this pertains to me I would like
you to leave why don't you go outside
and take a shot of insulin and have a
nap okay why do you always assume I have
diabetes you have a glass of apple juice
and tell me that you don't have diabetes
okay all right see just the noise you
made when you stood up I
could
I see the sales department are down
there they're in the engine room and
they are shoveling coal into the furnace
right I mean who saw the movie Titanic
they were very important in the movie
Titanic everyone in the engine room
drowned
okay I want to give you a nappy head
because you're
lesli well that's not your character's
name oh my God this is not a joke this
is not a
carnival car
[Music]
of
kind what it is nice job nice work
this says busiest be beaver I know it
says busiest no you screwed that up
didn't you I guess we have to go back
don't we we're wasting a lot of tape
give me that I want you all to be bons
okay Theon is a girl's name you need to
shut the
up here's your
headline Scranton Paper Company Dunder
Mifflin apologizes to value client some
companies still know how business is
done it's more like the whole
article over the gums and through the
lips look out
stomach there we
go I don't mean to be crass but get
prepared to get wet
because God wow there double meaning in
that there wasn't you couldn't even get
through it it's the most horrible thing
I'm so sorry when he came out for soccer
practice I I pinched
him where did you pinch
him y want to know what I was in for no
no hey where you busy what do you need
we're rolling Melissa Hi how are you I
thought somebody just said Mel so you
all want to know what I'm
for uh I know I used to be a temp here
and now I'm your boss and I understand
how that must be weird for you but
you I'm really sorry I broke that was
too
good well I'd do the scene but BJ's not
here and
resetting when IJ go okay so we're all
leaving for the hospital at 1 o' so free
and free I can take
three we're leaving for the hospital at
1 Freedom
tree sorry let's just go through that
part okay we're leaving for the hospital
at 1 like a freedom treat I
can I guess what surround sound means is
that right over here
CH two
speakers damn we have two
speakers what honey oh Jesus this is
terrible we'll never finish this episode
um check this out
folds the
wall
sorry oh my well hello
everybody hello
everybody oh man fors someone's fault
well no it's
it's not it's not anybody's fault you
know what let's just look at the lines
and then we'll do the scene
again Phyllis did I or did I not say
fruit you did say fruit and what is that
cake and what did I say
fruit
Sor is is this is this funny to you
Phyllis she's nervous yeah well she
should be nervous because I'm about to
kick her
ass I'm GNA walk in
again this is d
right and this
copier
is
working fine that's the original
[Laughter]
well could not have made a better
noise Phyllis we gave you one hell of a
wedding shower it was a golden shower
Phyllis we all gave you a
gold we all came in this room for your
wedding and gave you
a we all came in here and gave you a
golden shower well where's my golden
sh you don't have to do this I can do
this what is wrong with me
something oh God you said you would
laugh what happened to four and three
Michael it's okay 2 minutes is too soon
5 minutes and 2 minutes is a very big
difference going to hold it together
[Music]
[Laughter]
I told you War me 5 minutes what
happened to four and three because 2
minutes doesn't do us any good come here
what you got hold it together
okay sit on your lap you can sit on my
lap all you want because I am a male
Santa and that is something that Phyllis
cannot do oh my God okay this is really
comfortable okay tell me what you want
little boy
I don't know I didn't know you were
going to ask me that what did you think
was going to happen I didn't know no
one's ever let me sit on their lap
before hurry up just say some
toys can can you give me some choices oh
my God Kevin please
sorry copper squat here we
go sorry
Sor squat I'm glad what would you like
for Christmas little
Kevin I don't
know I didn't know you were going to ask
me that well what did you think was
going to happen
here
sorry you had a curiosity do you have
any other characters oh I'm working on
Scranton
Strangler I'm going to get you what do
you
[Laughter]
think oh I'm working on a new one
Granton Strangler I'm going to kill
you oh I'm working on the Granton
Strangler don't start laughing I'm
working I'm working on a new one strant
Strangler I'm killing now you now you
with the Laughing Kelly is even worse
than Daryl we have three sex or or heavy
petting closets one masturbation closet
does anyone have a problem with that yes
gay closet five that was five closet
that's that wasn't the problem three
heavy petting closets one masturbation
closet and one gay closet absolutely I
don't no problem everybody happy with
the glory hole what well I heard about
it somewh holy fifth closet will have a
glory
hole this here is a Ron test kit okay
I'll be putting them everywhere and
please don't throw these out
this is a raon test
kit please don't throw these
out see them all over the
[Laughter]
office
[Music]
[Laughter]
Mommy uh have you
seen Michael
oh oh hey there you
are
take